c'était l'épreuve des poteaux de koh
lanta
au départ on était sans cesse ses dix
minutes 20 minutes 30 minutes
et au final je sais 6 heures dessus et
j'ai rien de gagné ouvrez l'odeur
symbolique ce pas messieurs merci à vous
[Musique]
le plus compliqué moments compliqués
moment être moins de macri du chocolat
alors c'est pas le fait de voir un plat
la tête assez suis facilement c'est
surtout d'en avoir sur d'autres affaires
personnelles et la note de bons soucis
et l'espagne alors écoutez j'ai d'autres
supports effectivement comme le chocolat
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bon chroniqueur préféré journée autres
cas parce qu'il s'agit d'une
chroniqueuse et je trouve que isabelle
morini-bosc manière chroniqueur les deux
parties depuis très longtemps et il est
encore à régler en fait donc ça n'a pas
lieu n'a pas maintenant il y en a pas à
l'imaginer j'avais un haineux dans
l'équipe
j'aurais eu l'obligation de me le
coltine et dans son élan
même pas ils vers dette mais en france
quand gilles verdez le bas de l'arbre où
on coupe et hier soir nam a demandé à
mathieu delormeau de fermer sa gueule
pour une fois n'a pas dit de conneries
et bim
deuxième chose
[Applaudissements]
nettoierait mois en fait il est bon
quand il est pas un maximum de balles on
a quand même beaucoup rigoler entre la
laponie la tunisie mois en huile de
temps en temps les shooteurs pikachu en
passant par les grosses rigolades
en ce moment j'ai adoré qu'elles sont
[Applaudissements]
mon avis préféré c'est l'oiseau d'auteur
vous imaginez le nombre de personnes qui
sont passées dégoulinant de sueur ce
costume affreux peut alors je le dis
pour les chroniqueurs regarder qui était
derrière c'est quand même c'est fabrice
conca spectateurs c'est le numéro et
ward h2o c'est celui qui fait les paye
oui
écoutez ses 10 ans d pfv aura été un
dixième anniversaire
c'est comme oublié de fêter son avenir
sa voix la france je vais rose nous
reposer jusqu'à la nouba une métro vers
à faire du bien la série la proposent
soit bien parce que la vision de man et
qui doit être encore plus haut on
portera donc les délires on est là pour
toi parce que très bien là où je suis
quotidienne